i've always been a radical i've always
challenged the status quo
do you feel that you're part of a
libertarian movement no i don't
know so what are you there well i'm not
a part of a movement i've never been
a part of movement i just
i just do my own thing walter williams
the free market scholar and iconoclast
died last week at the age of 84. he was
the author of 13 books and was best
known for his work demonstrating that
government interference in the free
market has been especially harmful
to black americans born in 1936
williams grew up in the richard allen
homes one of philadelphia's first
housing projects i broke out of the
north philadelphia ghetto nearly 30
years ago
and so did most of my friends when he
was a small child his father
deserted his family he was brought up by
his mother a high school dropout
and the family spent time on welfare but
williams would later draw a distinction
between material poverty
and what he called poverty of the spirit
even though
we grew up poor we didn't we didn't
consider ourselves poor that as a matter
of fact during those days to call
somebody poor was an insult when i was a
kid
my mother used to always say to us she
says you know we have a beer pocketbook
but we have champagne taste williams
worked as a taxi driver in the city of
brotherly love and was once ordered out
of his cab by a white police officer
beaten up and then charged with
disorderly conduct he was drafted into
the army and while stationed in georgia
kept getting in
trouble occasionally with his fists for
standing up to the racism of white
officers
but he came to believe that
discrimination should be legal
just as long as it didn't involve
government resources
one of my strong values is freedom of
association
if you believe in freedom of association
you have to accept that people will
associate in ways that you find
offensive
and i believe people have the right to
discriminate on any basis they want so
long as they're not using
a government for me discrimination is
just simply an act of choice
after the army williams studied
economics at california state college
and then went to ucla for graduate
school where he was exposed to titans of
free-market economics including
milton friedman james buchanan and
ucla's department chair
armin alcion flunking economic theory
the first time around he wrote in his
memoir
i later realized did have a benefit it
convinced me that ucla professors didn't
care anything about my race
they'd flunk me just as they'd flunk
anyone else who didn't make the grade
i don't judge people by colors i say
that well
jay you're you're a man just like i am
and
that's what my stepfather used to say he
says every man stands up to piss and
he's
whatever he is after that in 1977
williams started writing a weekly column
which was eventually syndicated in 140
newspapers
he was also a contributor to reason
magazine and served as a trustee
on the board of reason foundation the
nonprofit that publishes reason tv
for all his individual accomplishments
williams was especially proud of his
role in making george mason university's
economics department
a home for free market radicals there
was considerable hostility towards our
department
and i had a lot of difficulty and so i
just said well
the only way i'm going to improve the
department is to try to privatize the
department and actually go out and raise
money
last week his former colleagues at
george mason paid tribute to their
mentor and friend
gmu econ has lost an iconic and heroic
figure wrote pete betke he taught with
wit and passion the logic of economic
reasoning he is one of my few heroes
wrote don boudreau liberty is the
rare state of affairs in mankind's
history arbitrary abuse and control by
others
is the standard dish even now and all
the tendencies are
is for us to have greater and greater
amounts of our liberty uh usurped by
uh government rest in peace
walter williams